head coach of the indianapolis colts
back here on the program always great to
have frank reich on the show
how are you coach rich i'm doing well
how about yourself better for talking to
you
better for talking to you what do you
make of the narrative that we have in
the national football league media that
you and you alone have the secret sauce
for carson wentz
let me just jump right in head first on
that subject with you what are you i
i appreciate you i appreciate you
jumping in on that no
you know it's always anybody who's who
i've ever worked with or the staffs i've
ever worked on know it's always a
collaborative approach i
never feel like hey i want to do my part
but it's a collaborative approach
with the player the coaches together the
team um
you know that that's what it's the whole
process and it's the whole group so
that's the way we'll approach it here
so how are you approaching it with uh
with carson wentz what was your first
conversation with him likes
when you were allowed to when this
became official and you were allowed to
connect and things of that nature
yeah no doubt and it's what exactly what
you would think and want it to be rich
or what anybody would want it to be what
carson would want it to be
you know you move teams you go through
what carson has gone through
and and an opportunity like this
presents itself
you use it for what it is it's time to
hit the reset button go back to the
basics
the front amount start you know starting
at the very beginning and
um you know you try to discipline
yourself to do that as a player every
year no matter what
but it's hard to do once you're you know
you get things going but you go through
something like this a new team new
beginning
let's let's let's use this to our
advantage carson let's and and
and if you know carson the way i know
him he's embracing that he wants that
and
he's working real hard and and you know
looking forward to it and uh
off to a good start so yeah i mean
obviously you have the ability to hit
the
the reset button but based on your
knowledge of him and when he's at his
best
i mean when he when he dove for the end
zone and had the
the the mistake of of diving for an end
zone with aaron donald barreling in on
him in the los angeles coliseum a couple
years ago that was the mvp of the
of the season i mean he was the mvp up
until that very moment when his knee was
blown out we all know what happened with
nick foles after that
but you're right and he was at at that
point i think
everyone pretty much agrees you know
maybe it could be already but he's
probably
uh that day if the voting's that day
he's the mvp but
so i believe he's fully capable of that
but you know we
here like most teams you know
yeah we want players who can produce at
that level
but uh you know we want to do the
ordinary things
in an extraordinary way and just play
just do your job at the position that
you play be the quarterback of this team
you know a lot of that mvp season
was due to the fact that he had a great
offensive line in front of him in 2017
that was playing at a very high level
there was a good running game
there was a good defense there was good
special teams there was good coaching
there was really good play calling by
doug peterson
um you know it was and that all
contributed to that so
that that's the approach here you know
we i do believe that carson has
um what it takes to have an mvp type
season
but i also believe that at that at this
position it starts up front with this
team you know chris ballard and i when
we talk about it
we talk about building this team from
the inside out from the front o-line
d-line quarterback
so you know and then derry slanter he's
kind of the quarterback of the defense
so
that's kind of how we're going to roll
well and in just one
uh a few more on this subject matter
frank reicher the colts here
on the rich eisen show how much though
you know obviously it is collaborative
and uh i know your owner is somebody who
uh
delegates and then lets those people do
their jobs
and um but how much do were you in this
conversation with chris ballot and
everyone else saying i got this
when it it came a call from philadelphia
or maybe vice versa to check on things
that uh it's possible to get carson
wentz here well no it was it was what
you just said rich it was you know mr
irsay it was chris bowers and myself
and so you know naturally at this
position with my history
you know they they were gracious enough
to you know listen and lean on my
knowledge and experience with carson but
it was collaborative in its decision
between the three of us
you know obviously mr irsay has to write
the checks
so and chris has to you know coordinate
the trade
and figure out how that's going to
affect the dynamics of our whole team so
um i played my part to give my
evaluation of who
carson is obviously um you know mr
hersey as you know
being around us you know he's got a
pretty astute opinion on matters as well
and
his perspective and obviously chris is
one of the top evaluators in this league
so it was a really dynamic uh
collaborative effort and um and
thankfully we were able to get done work
work it out with philly where it was a
long arduous process you know nobody
wanted to give and
you know it eventually i think fell to
where what it was supposed to fall to
which was i think a fair deal for both
sides and then the last one on the
subject matter again because you know
carson wentz well and you know
philadelphia you will and i know that
you're hitting
the reset button but i'm i'm going to
ask a question that i'd love to give you
the
the floor on is the sense that the
drafting of jalen hurts
absolutely sent carson wentz into a bit
of a tailspin
that you know obviously the offensive
line and other things were were not
working on his beh
on his behalf but he allowed things that
he can't control to control him
uh i'm wondering what what you say about
that now that he is your quarterback
in indianapolis yeah well well first of
all i really don't have
i don't think that's the case i mean
that's how i feel about it that's my
opinion that i don't think
the drafting of another player sent
carson uh you know in a tailspin um i
think there was
uh i think it's complicated i think
there's
it was a a lot of different dynamics
you know everybody's you know when he's
winner losing this league everybody
should
share should share in the success and
everybody should share and blame it
usually doesn't work that way
you know the quarterback head coach
whoever gm's you know
tend to be the focal point so you know
carson
carson took his share of being the focal
point of the blame and that's part of
the process of being a quarterback in
this league and you got to be a big boy
and be able to take it but
um you know now is an opportunity to hit
the reset button it's an opportunity for
the eagles to set the reset button and
obviously
rich you know i mean just because from
our past guy you know
nothing that i want more than to see the
eagles succeed and this be a win-win for
both teams and
the jaylen hertz is successful it's all
good i love great quarterback play but
i'm glad we got our
i'm glad we got our guy frank reich
indianapolis colts here on the rich
eisen show as if
we needed more evidence of
the intelligence of you and chris
ballard together
you went ahead and drafted a michigan
man in your first round
frank so um congratulations on that
uh i love this kid quitty pay um i
assume you
um clearly uh got to know him very well
and his story what
attracted you to quitty pay to bestow
your first round selection 21st overall
on him
yeah well you know you're going to put a
first round uh first round selection on
the guy you better feel great about the
tape you better feel great about the
person
and you know that's really important to
us so
you know it came to it came to day one
and uh
of the draft and you know chris i
remember chris coming in and
you know the whole way up to the draft
feeling like that was our guy but then
you know chris coming in and and we
didn't think he was going to get to us
um but chris coming in that day said i
got a good feeling
you know i got a good feeling i got a
good feeling we're gonna get him
and uh so he just he embodies what we're
about this is the kind of guy who
has put on tape on and off the field in
the locker room
the kind of player that we want that is
you know productive
tough um strong mental toughness great
team first player who we think is going
to continue to ascend
and get even better and uh the rest of
your draft
um because then you you hit the
defensive line again
uh safety on the back end fifth overall
uh so three of the first four
of your your choices went um on the
defensive side of the ball walk me
through the thought process
on that because and as you know there's
a lot of talk in your town about needing
a left tackle and that was
not addressed in the draft this time
around
well i'm glad i'm glad you brought all
those up but first of all on di
andeo daio i should say um
boy are we excited about that pick i
know people say well he's got an
achilles but
i'm just telling you you watch us watch
the tape on this guy
i mean and this isn't you know this
isn't a career-ending type of injury
you know you're young and you're going
to heal quick and and complete
you know we think we got to done that we
think we got a guy who could have been
easily been a first-round draft pick um
we're
so excited about getting dialed we think
we got two great pass rushers
who who are going to get better and
better and who fit what we do they play
like we want to play they have the kind
of football character that we look for
in players
um you know and then you know getting
davis you know
and the tackle thing richard just didn't
yeah what we think did we want to take
it it just didn't play out i mean
the tackles that we had in mind that we
hoped fell at the right spots it just
never happened
were we was chris talking and wheeling
dealing don't yeah but it just never
it just it just was never right but we
were super excited to get the two guys
that we got
and you know we have a lot we have other
ways that we can
continue to build our team and we'll
continue to evaluate all options
we were excited to get granson you know
tight end we think
he's dynamic with the ball in his hands
we think he's explosive
um you know so we think he can add some
play-making element to our offense
um so that's a quick summary of those
guys and i guess and last one for you
uh a kid that a lot of college football
fans are familiar with is the
quarterback you took in the sixth round
sam allen you're what
what are you what are you what attracted
you to him and uh you know we all know
sixth round selections at quarterback
can
can work what out what what are your
thoughts on that subject with him and
the future you see with him well again
you go back to two things we we always
go but you know the two things every
team goes to
go to the tape and then go to the locker
room and go to the tape and go to the
locker room and what kind of
what kind of a player do you see you see
the tape you see this guy's a winner you
know nothing's too big for him he has
ways of making plays
he's played a lot of winning football he
has a unique ability to extend plays
in his own unique fact i've been around
guys like this before
or seen guys like this many times that
you know he's not a
he's not going to why you know you look
at his 40 time that's not going to wow
you but he has
he has this unique vision and balance
and knack in the pocket that that we're
excited about
um and then he's super smart super
football smart great teammate
so we think it's a good dynamic in the
quarterback room and we think we got a
good quarterback room you know easton
you know we drafted easton last year and
excited excited about him
and so we'll just continue to develop
those guys coach thanks for the time i
appreciate it let's
let's chat uh down the line in the
summer time and uh
and and reconnect and i always
appreciate our chats thank you
appreciate it
you got it rich you got it that's frank
wright head coach of the indianapolis
colts